[Music]
that's singer songwriter charlie
crockett with his soulful version of
jerry reads i feel for you crockett's
new album little gl presents jukebox
charlie is out today he's on a
headlining tour right now and will join
willie nelson on the road this summer
including on his annual 4th of july
picnic well last september crockett was
named emerging act of the year at the
americana awards that's where our
anthony mason first saw him anthony you
have a good time
sure did good morning charlie crockett
is a descendant of american folk hero
davey crockett charlie's rise in the
music industry is something of a folk
story as well we met up with a 38 year
old in new orleans where he used to
spend eight hours a day playing on
street corners for spare change
[Music]
charlie crockett came up the hard way
for most of his life the texas-born
singer lived on the road what do you
think of his home
bob marley said uh my home is in my head
you know or wherever i lay my hat i'm
gonna
get up out of texas
[Music]
i am a
person that was an itinerant
and all the music i know
i learned that way
[Music]
did you choose to live an itinerant life
or did that just happen
i don't think you really choose
to be an itinerant really
my brother and i got in a lot of trouble
when i was younger he went to jail and
eventually my sister passed away from
her
the troubles that she had and she had an
addiction yeah
yeah well she struggled with alcohol
and
you know my brother went to prison for
the kind of stuff that
he was doing that he pulled me into
which i never blamed him for that really
a lot of people break the law out of
desperation
his brother served a seven year sentence
for money laundering in a federal
conspiracy case i couldn't see any way
out of it besides giving
like just giving myself to the highway
that highway took him out of texas to
california then to new orleans where he
met charlie mills one day in the french
quarter i was just looking for somebody
to jam
and uh he came by with like three other
people and everybody had guitars i was
like hey you guys want to jam
and he was like yeah and then
the rest is as they say
and then i asked him for a place to stay
he's my line
the joker
stands in the middle mills taught
crockett the traditional songs that
attract a crowd
so take a look at me
i'm just a clown
learned all that here i learned almost
all that from charlie yeah
so so how was he back in the day out on
the street as a performer
oh i mean yeah true dynamic i mean
you could he'd be singing down there but
you can hear him two blocks over
i've paid the calls
but crockett kept moving what made you
go to new york in the first place i went
to new york city i think believing that
like a lot of people that i was gonna go
there
and
conquer the empire
right yeah and we all know
that that city has a is too big
[Music]
he played in the subways with a
collective of musicians who called
themselves the train robbers
i did get a record deal on the subway
cars and i got up in the canopies of new
york city
sony signed crockett but he says they
tried to package him and you weren't
going to be packaged
i wasn't going to be packaged and i i
couldn't have handled it even if i
wanted to be packaged i couldn't handle
it i thank you
lucky
it feels like something changed about
five or six years ago
yeah yeah i i went to jail
i went to jail in virginia for what i
got caught with a whole bunch of
ganja in the trunk of this car i was
driving between
2014 and 2016 when i got convicted my
sister died she wasn't 40 years old i
just remember thinking man you're gonna
be dead
and you're definitely gonna really do
some time
in prison
if you don't
figure this out that's when i really
started taking recording seriously
[Music]
in the past seven years crockett has
released a dozen albums
there is a man you'll hear about he
toured more than 200 days in 2018
and his unique blend of country thanks
for dropping by but you don't need to
see
folk
if my brother
refused me at his door and the blues
in the night
[Music]
but suddenly it all seemed in jeopardy
in early 2019 when crockett learned he
had a congenital heart condition you had
open heart surgery
were you scared
yeah brother
i was real scared they told you if you
didn't do it you could die
yeah
they told me if i didn't do it i would
die
the emergency surgery to replace a heart
valve was successful it's a hell of a
curveball though just when you were when
things were sort of starting to break
your way yeah
yeah yeah i've had a lot of that you
know i feel like
most people
you know in america feel like they just
can't get
a break how does it feel to have gotten
a break
did i get one
that's it
does it feel like you have finally
yeah kinda i guess
a little bit
are you suspicious of that in any way
yeah
always you know i know how to put out a
lot of records
and i know how to put on
a show and i'm the best at that that
i've ever been that's all i can rely on
you know that's all i can be sure of so
take a look at me
i'm just a clown
i'm always treating it
like the guy
playing out of a guitar case on the
corner
[Music]
yeah
we totally get that anthony mason
joining us now he is such a sweet
classic reminds me of the old guys from
there there's something vintage about
him he's only 38 years old and and i
think that comes from coming up on the
streets i mean he is one of the most
compelling live performers i've ever
seen and i think that comes from playing
for quarters and trying to get people's
attention while they pass you the
resiliency yes can we also talk about
his clothes yeah
so well-dressed i know
you look great and he asked himself did
i get a break yes an anthony mason sit
down profile in the music business that
counts as a break i know you may not
look at it that way i can say it anthony
thanks a lot